ahora que sabemos un poco de inflación
deflación etcétera
en esta ocasión quiero introducir les la
idea de hiper de hiper inflación y sus
consecuencias en el mundo la
hiperinflación es el caso en el que la
inflación se vuelve salvaje degenerada
bueno en general podemos decir que la
hiperinflación ocurriría cuando un
gobierno empieza a imprimir como loco y
como de generado dinero entonces voy a
escribirlo un gobierno imprime como loco
dinero y por un momento no dice que
padre pues todos vamos a ser ricos nos
vamos a hacer millonarios todos sin
embargo hay que tener cuidado porque
esto da pie a un ciclo imagínense a este
gobierno que no tiene otra forma de
obtener ingresos y empieza a imprimir
mucho dinero bueno por lo tanto los
precios empiezan a aumentar de manera
rapidísima si yo veo que todos tienen
dinero entonces aumento el precio de mi
producto
ahora bien el gobierno dice todo está
aumentando de precio por lo tanto en
prima más dinero y seguramente ya desde
aquí puedes ver que esto se va a
convertir en un verdadero caos tal vez
se pueden imaginar
una inflación muy grande del 5% o del
10% que se yo ahora imagínense una
inflación del 5% o del 10% por hora por
cada hora esto empieza a enloquecer en
este momento no habría por qué tener
billetes en la bolsa y entonces todos se
empezarían a apuntar bien los materiales
por ejemplo el precio del pan aumentaría
cada minuto o cada hora también el
precio los zapatos sobre lo que ustedes
quieran y como los precios van a
aumentar entonces las personas van a ir
a comprar todos los zapatos que puedan
por lo tanto los van a acumular en su
casa imagínense una casa llena de
zapatos todos van a ir a querer comprar
sus zapatos pero entonces el dueño de la
tienda de zapatos nada tonto va a decir
voy a guardar algunos zapatos porque
después de un tiempo van a venderse en
un precio más caro por lo tanto los
precios vuelven a aumentar imagínense
llega una persona a la tienda a comprar
pan pero como tiene dinero decide
comprar todo el pan y entonces la
siguiente persona no puede comprar nada
de pan y esto nos lleva a que el precio
del pan se va hasta el techo y darse
cuenta que todo este lío empezó porque
el gobierno decidió imprimir billetes
como si fueran nueces
y ahora lo que quiero enseñarles son los
tres casos más impresionantes que se han
dado en el mundo sobre una
hiperinflación el primer caso está
situado en güímar alemania después de la
primera guerra mundial a la región se le
ocurrió reparar sus daños de la guerra
imprimiendo dinero el gobierno de ueimar
argumentó que ese dinero era para su
propia causa y entonces el primer dinero
como loco algunas personas dijeron que
estaban intentando destruir la economía
y así no tendrían que pagar las
reparaciones causadas por la primera
guerra mundial miren la gráfica si
nosotros empezamos con un marco de oro
al final de la primera guerra mundial
después de haber transcurrido dos años y
medio este marco de oro alemán vale diez
veces lo que valía al principio y aunque
aquí no estamos comparando la tasa de
interés fíjense lo extremo que se puso
en el eje es las 'íes' estamos hablando
una escala logarítmica en base 10 va
aumentando de 10 en 10 y fíjense en el
transcurso de 1 cuentas son uno dos tres
cuatro cinco o seis años de 1923 en 1918
aumentó el valor de este primer marco d
pero cuando que habíamos iniciado un
billón de veces un billón de veces su
valor guau son muchos ceros
el segundo caso famoso es el zimbabwe de
1980 al 2009 una vez más que imprimieron
dinero como locos
este es un billete de 100 billones de
dólares de zimbabwe en esta gráfica se
muestra la comparación del dólar de
zimbabue a comparación del dólar de eeuu
una vez más la escala es logarítmica y
llega hasta 10 elevado a la 30 y por
último el caso más extremo de
hiperinflación que alguna vez se ha
visto ocurrió en hungría después de la
segunda guerra mundial y este de aquí es
un billete de 10 millones de pesos